pandemics have haunted humanity for
centuries malaria
smallpox the plate and now the novel
coronavirus all of them have changed the
world we live in but have we changed the
way we do things
after the SARS outbreak 17 years ago the
world the world's countries promised
that they would act differently in the
future they promised that they would
take the threat of virus pandemics much
more seriously and I'm afraid that what
the latest pandemic shows is that we
have not learnt the lessons of the
dangers of a virus and that's a tragedy
it is a genuine human catastrophe
despite all the lessons from history the
suffering and loss from infectious
diseases we're caught up again in a
last-minute rush to contain an outbreak
with a cure for which success is
uncertain as it ever was
I've been Fazal and welcome what we
learn our lesson this time that's
something our leaders need to have a
good long think about it's also
something I'll ask a Harvard professor
about in a moment first a little history
lesson for you
pandemics have shaped history they of
course bring with them death an economic
devastation but they can also be a
catalyst for change progress and
innovation for example the plague the
most fatal pandemic in human history it
killed a third of Europe's population in
the 14th century as a result labor was
scarce and costly which resulted in
innovations like water wills and mills
as well as other machinery more houses
were built from stone which kept out
disease carrying rats and fleas in the
19th century there was a fifth pandemic
of cholera it spread throughout Asia and
Africa and hit Germany as well killing
nearly 9,000 people in the city of
Hamburg the economic loss 400 million
gold marks
but during this time the German
scientist Robert [ __ ] helped establish
how bacteria cause disease his findings
ultimately led to the development of
germ theory inadequate sanitation was
improved - then came the so-called
Spanish flu of 1918 the world's worst
pandemic to date as many as 50 million
people died after the disease spread
from animals to young farmers drafted
for war in the United States many cities
such as st. Louis shut down to contain
the outbreak but Philadelphia allowed a
huge parade to go ahead which sparked
mass infections it endured twice as many
deaths the worst hit US City the Spanish
flu ended up causing more deaths than
the first world war but it led to
improved hygiene and advances in
virology which brings us to today and
covert nineteen tens of thousands of so
far died and global isolation measures
have led to a shutdown of the world
economy millions of people have lost
their jobs businesses have folded no one
knows what the economic recovery will
look like but there's relief for the
environment with factories closing air
pollution has plunged many workers have
moved on line sparking a digital
revolution from public services to
health care the pandemic is remaking the
world in real-time the question is what
comes next
David Jones is a Harvard college
professor from the Faculty of Medicine
professor tell us how unique this
disease actually is first of all I don't
think we know that yet in terms of both
how infectious it is and how deadly it
is it's currently infectious enough to
have spread quickly around the world but
it's probably not as infectious as a
disease like measles it's deadly enough
to have caused major problems where now
is approaching 300,000 deaths worldwide
especially in the United States that's
more than the usual annual influenza
epidemics but not as bad as the
pandemics in 1957 or 1968 and certainly
not as bad as influenza in 1918 they
killed over 50 million people
take us back to smallpox well what was
the secret to eradicating that disease
the secret to smallpox eradication was
two things first smallpox doesn't have
an animal layer of animal reservoir so
once we get rid of it from humans it
should be gone forever and also we had a
very effective vaccine which allowed us
to control the disease but it wasn't
easy we had that vaccine in 1798 but the
last human case of smallpox wasn't until
1978 a hundred and eighty years later
Wow in a required massive cooperation
between World Health Organization the
United States the Soviet Union and many
other countries to successfully
eradicate that disease and and and that
was cooperation that you're talking
about during what the Cold War I mean I
mean what's what's the difference
between how things were done back then
and now because we're not in a cold war
anymore they were willing to get
together to eradicate smallpox which I
think shows how terrified human
societies were of that disease we know
what we need to do now we know what
would be required to contain kovat we
just have to figure out how we can get
the cooperation in the consensus about
the best way to proceed
and I find it pretty hard to get some
sort of consensus on a societal basis I
mean just amongst my friends and
workmates well what about how society
has reacted throughout the ages what is
telling their societies have been
dealing with pandemics for as long as we
have lived in cities and we have learned
a lot from that history for instance we
have learned that many epidemics can be
controlled through isolation and
Quarantine that's a very old technique
and it has worked very well in certain
situations the other disease that we
seem to have eradicated is SARS
after killing 774 people in 2002 and
2003 there hasn't been a case of SARS
since 2004 and that was done entirely
with surveillance and isolation without
a vaccine so we know what to do if we
set our minds to it what will be
required to eradicate kovin it would be
wonderful if we develop a vaccine it
will be wonderful if we develop
effective tree
but many countries have done a terrific
job with the technology we already have
China and Germany have significantly
reduced cases Australia and New Zealand
are on the verge of declaring the
disease contained but in many countries
especially in the United States but many
other countries in the world the disease
is continuing to spread
we just need to mobilize the resources
and the political will to do what we
already know and then we should be able
to achieve success but based on on what
sort of success because why are some
infectious diseases able to be wiped out
totally and others not there are many
things that determine whether or not we
can eradicate a disease smallpox is a
great example where we have done that
and possibly SARS but there are also
diseases that could have been better
contained where we have failed HIV is
the most tragic example we knew what we
needed to do in the 1980s to contain
that disease and we were unable to do so
we now have very effective treatment for
HIV if we got every person on the planet
who now has HIV to take medicines
reliably if we get them the medicines we
could eradicate HIV but we haven't done
that yet and what that shows is it's not
simply a question of having the
technology needed to eradicate a disease
but also to have the systems in place to
provide that care that treatment and the
political will to bring eradication
campaigns to fruition it's too soon to
tell what will happen with Kovan if
there's an animal reservoir it will be
very hard to eradicate but the success
of some countries shows that tremendous
progress can be made and we just need to
bring that progress to the rest of the
world David Jones Harvard University
thank you very much I'm sure you've got
lots of questions too now science
correspondent Eric Williams has been
busy answering all the questions you've
been sending us keep doing that it keeps
Derrick busy
we'll over-the-counter allergy medicines
like claritin suppress your body's
immune reaction to covet 19 the active
ingredient in the medicine you mentioned
is loratadine that's an antihistamine
now antihistamines reduce allergy
symptoms by blocking histamine that's a
compound that's released by your immune
system during an allergic reaction it
plays a central role in the itching and
the and the swelling that hay fever
sufferers experience now because the
medication interferes with an immune
response which is actually kind of a
hyper immune response many people who
suffer from allergies are worried that
it could make them more vulnerable to
infection with Soros Cove to to take
antihistamines currently however all the
national allergy organizations I looked
at are still saying that antihistamines
are safe to take during the pandemic if
that changes I'll let you know here has
the lid amide being tested among the
existing medications that are currently
being tested as treatments for covered
19 is one with an absolutely terrible
reputation the lid amide is best known
as the drug that back in the 1960s
caused severe birth defects in the
babies of pregnant women who who took it
from morning sickness but it's since
been redeemed to some extent and has
proved effective against symptoms in a
range of medical conditions among them
infections with the h1n1 flu virus
because the lid amide has
anti-inflammatory effects researchers in
different studies are now looking at
whether it can slow or even stop lung
damage in patients with severe cases of
kovat 19 but that work is still ongoing
it's still too early to know whether it
could eventually prove to be an
effective treatment is the internal
structure and behavior of Tsarskoe v2
clearly visible under
microscope not under a light microscope
um the virus is only around a hundred
nanometers in diameter that's that's
much smaller than the wavelengths of
light that our eyes are able to perceive
that means that under a light microscope
the corona virus is effectively
invisible to obtain images of it we have
to use electron microscopes by
bombarding samples of the virus with
streams of of tiny subatomic particles
electron microscopes can resolve
structures down to around a single
nanometer so they can reveal source code
to in pretty short detail